the Netflix documentary series Tiger
King has found a captive audience stuck
at home during coronavirus lockdowns
there's really only one big story that
everybody's talking about tiger king
tiger king tiger king it has to be seen
to be believed
even then it's so wild the protagonists
personalities and deep-seated rivalry
have become cultural touchstones making
lines like this you know you cool cats
and kittens it's Carol into viral memes
Tiger King elevated the bizarre culture
of tiger ownership in the United States
but it didn't reveal how prolific this
culture really is that's because no
one's really sure they're somewhere
between 5,000 and 15,000 captive tigers
living in the u.s. today that's a lot
more than the roughly 3500 Tigers living
in the wild their numbers have fallen
for decades due to poaching and loss of
habitat the vast majority of Tigers
living in the United States don't live
in zoos they're owned by private
individuals because of this there isn't
a clear record of how many tigers there
are in the United States and where
exactly they're being kept according to
legal experts and animal rights
activists the law is meant to protect
tigers actually led to their
proliferation in this country putting
the animals lives in public safety at
risk
most of the Tigers in the US weren't
rescued abroad or smuggled in they were
born here there are nine subspecies of
tigers three are extinct in the
remaining six are endangered accredited
zoos in the united states have breeding
programs designed to sustain endangered
tiger populations but those make up a
small fraction of the tiger is believed
to be in the u.s. most are bred at
so-called roadside zoos it's really not
a zoo it's just a menagerie of animals
they offer pay-to-play experiences where
you get Tiger baby time where you can
play on the floor with baby animals
including Tigers this contact with baby
Tigers is called cub petting and can be
big business for roadside zoos
Claude petting is extremely lucrative
for exhibitors in fact one cog can yield
up to a million dollars in revenue
during its lifetime the US Department of
Agriculture which regulates roadside
zoos allows Cub petting but recommends
it be limited to cubs between 8 and 12
weeks old with such a limited window for
public interactions roadside zoos are
compelled to keep breeding tigers
experts say that this demand for Cubs
has led to extensive crossbreeding of
tigers in the United States to the point
where most are no longer genetically
similar to those found in the wild the
most notorious example of this is the
white tiger white Tigers are not a
separate subspecies yet here in the
United States exhibitors love to read
them the problem is these Tigers have to
be heavily inbred along with the white
coloring comes really really premature
death renal failure and serious kidney
problems - and also facial deformities
as many as 95% of the Tigers in the
United States are believed to be these
so-called generic Tigers and for a long
time the US government didn't regulate
them like other subspecies Tigers in the
United States are protected by the
Endangered Species Act this law
prohibits the sale and transportation of
endangered animals unless you get a
permit from the US Fish and Wildlife
Service and that permit application has
to be supported by some sort of
demonstration that the underlying
activity benefits the species survival
in the wild in 1998 the Fish and
Wildlife Service removed the permitting
requirements for generic Tigers their
reasoning was that these Tigers lacked
conservation value meaning if they
didn't exist in the wild then there was
no reason to regulate their movement
here in the US this created a loophole
for breeders to sell off their generic
Tigers that were too old for cub heading
and you would see without fail every
single month tiger cubs available for
sale for a couple hundred bucks or even
for free once
past that age where they could no longer
be legally handled by the public
loophole was closed in 2016 but experts
say by then
thousands of Tigers had made their way
across the country that loophole to
exist for 18 years created an
environment where enough fighters were
read as quickly as possible for many of
them to fall into a black hole states
vary in their restrictions of big cat
ownership from outright bans to no
restrictions at all which experts say
leads to them falling into inexperienced
hands in abusive situations private
ownership advocates contend that while
irresponsible big cat ownership can lead
to abuse this represents a small portion
of private owners and as declined as new
owners have become better educated about
big cats no private individual has the
capability of providing a humane
existence for these animals and you
cannot tame an apex predator you cannot
take the wild out of a tiger
dozens of exotic animals escaped from an
animal reserve in Zanesville deputies
armed with assault rifles went to the
animal farm where they found the owner
dead animal cages open in 2011 an Ohio
man released dozens of his privately
owned exotic animals including 18 Tigers
into the local community he released
these animals into the community placed
first responders in an absolutely no-win
situation where they were forced to
literally slaughter these animals in
order to keep the community safe so
that's what the big cat Public Safety
Act would help solve the big cat Public
Safety Act is pending legislation that
if enacted would ban private ownership
of big cats in banned public
interactions like cub petting at
roadside zoos opponents of the
legislation say laws currently on the
books are sufficient to protect big cats
and that the problem lies with lack of
enforcement they also contend that a
blanket ban on private big cat ownership
would create a precedent to ban other
exotic pets I'm
I love Tigers because Tigers are the
most iconic of the big cat species
they're really representative of how we
look at conservation of protected
animals their role is much bigger than
just Tigers themselves
[Music]